tens of thousands of people in the
Philippines are fleeing their homes as
scientists warn a volcano could erupt
within hours or days tal volcano and
target a about 66 kilometers south of
Manila started spewing ash and lava on
Sunday six thousand people have already
been evacuated from one Island with
thousands more leaving coastal towns the
ash grounded all flights from Manila
Airport on Sunday night as John Joe
Regan reports ash and steam spew one
kilometer into the air as the Tower
volcano explodes south of the Philippine
capital Manila authorities here say
there's been a fast escalation of
volcanic activity and they've warned it
could erupt lava within weeks
ash rained down on several villages and
cities nearby and kilometers away
prompting a mass evacuation thousands of
people have been told to leave their
homes when the volcano emitted steam we
ran away up here the road was crowded
thick ash and pebbles were falling the
volcano has created its own weather
system and tremors have been felt nearby
it's not known when people will be able
to return we are evacuating we left all
of our belongings behind everyone has
left all international and domestic
flights had to be cancelled at Manila's
main International Airport as the
Philippines waits to see what the towel
volcano will do next John Joe Regan
al-jazeera